We also should check out
the SweepWatchFaceService to see
how to implement smoothly
moving analog watch hands.
Most of the concepts in this code are
the same as in the digital service we
just reviewed.
Let's look at onDraw.
If we scroll down,
you can see at the end we call
invalidate if we're in interactive mode.
This forces an immediate
refresh as soon as possible,
giving the smooth second-hand movement.
Also, let's have a quick
look at onSurfaceChanged.
This method is called to give us
the dimensions of the display and
typically happens once when
the watch face is started.
This is where we resize
the background image once so
it's ready for
use in the Android method later.